uh Cube uh I saw I saw you talk about
big three and uh kind of Adam Silver's
like lack of support yeah um he need to
go I saw you so I I mean yeah I mean
you're obviously a big NBA fan
historically you've been one of the
biggest Laker fans yes sitting Courtside
all the years yeah
um well I was in my Suite when I wasn't
uh foot on the wood but I was would you
say you were uh lack of approval of a
guy like Adam Silver has affected you
watching the product as a fan of course
you know understanding the things that
they're doing to prevent the big three
from growing
mainly uh considering our league as
competition which is [ __ ] ridiculous
with three on three we've been around
six years they're five on five they've
been around 76 years right it's no
competition we're complementary and but
labeling us competition prevents other
NBA owners from investing
and if you even think you want to own an
NBA team
you won't invest because this would
disqualify you if you invest in a big
three before you bought your NBA team
wow so it eliminates a lot of potential
investors they also are you know going
to to sponsors that they work with and
telling them don't work with it the
three so it's a major issue all he has
to do is with is is not include the big
three in that Clause as as a competing
League
and then we can work with a lot of the
same people
um but you know this is a a black owned
League it has
um you know some of the greatest Hall of
Famers that ever played
involved in the league as coaches you
know from Dr J to Rick Barry to also
people who are actively involved in like
the NBA culture who commentated on TV
and all that yeah so these are
you know NBA legends who helped us form
this lead NBA family and and for them to
[ __ ] on it like that I think uh is very
disrespectful you know Dr J Iceman Rick
Barry they didn't make a lot of money in
the NBA but the NBA made a lot of money
off them and for them to [ __ ] on a
league that they're involved in that's
three on three uh
to me shows that Adam Silver is out of
touch
he was supposed to bring ice cube and
say I would love to be a part of it and
I want you to be the president of the
journey too we offered the NBA 10 of the
league before we started so we went in
bearing gifts he told told us uh thank
you but no thank you
and then proceeded to [ __ ] with us for
these last six years what's crazy
because it's the competition part is
wild it's like you guys are obviously
uh it's a different time of the year and
it's all it's all players who are known
through the NBA so it just raises brand
awareness for the NBA players that the
NBA have overlooked and you know they
come and get our players and invite I
mean Joe Johnson got signed off of his
run in the big three again they invite
him to the NBA camps we have general
managers coming to the game owners
everybody comes you think David Stern
would have embraced it might have been
worse I don't think so but David Stern
did like what we were doing
but he couldn't get involved because
he's you know acts commissioner yeah
ex-commissioner with the NBA and Adam
Silver they're just lawyers when it
comes down to it right at the end of the
day they are just lawyers and I think
he's making a big mistake and I think
not uh embracing The Big Three will be
his downfall
let me ask you this because do you think
it could take somebody like
a Steph Curry or like a LeBron
to kind of step in and fully Embrace a
league like that to kind of change
someone like Adam Silver's perspective
on it maybe you know uh LeBron has come
to our games you know he went to the
championship in uh 2019
um Michael Jordan loves our league [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah I'm surprised he didn't
just say give me one I go one round with
y'all just to show you I don't think you
want to get out there you know I think
that's the past but but for the most
part he loves the league and uh you know
people like Adam told him not to work
with us and so it's just
it's time for this dude to go because
he's showing that he's not really down
with the culture hmm
what are the things you are are going to
try to do to grow The Big Three
um
put a better product on the court
um you know
take care of our sponsors
um
you know be the best Innovative new
league that the world of scene
um and you know uh get a fans what they
pay for you know it's like just just do
better uh and you know try to you know
get from under these grips that the NBA
has asunder because it is hurting us in
more ways than one yeah
yeah man [ __ ] I I I was telling you it's
an entertaining product for me I'm like
a basketball fanatic so like I'm just
like [ __ ] I could watch uh I don't know
Steven Jackson still player whoever it
is you know like three games are fun
they're fun they are what's the uh OG's
name Who had who changed his name and he
was on the nuggets
who's balling out for y'all
changed his name he remember he was
number one on the Nuggets back in the
day and he got in trouble because he
changed his name to his Muslim name
yeah it's like dope to see him get
Buckets on like way younger dudes
because he had a bad Shake in the NBA
because of that yeah you know what what
people don't realize about the big three
is it's his own game so just because you
got loose in the NBA
and you was the [ __ ] in the NBA don't
mean you're gonna come in the big three
and get loose and vice versa just
because people overlooked you in the NBA
don't mean you can't come in the big
three and make an impact and that's
what's been happening you know some
dudes think it's easy but in three on
three
you have to have all skills you can't
have no weaknesses you can't be a
specialist can't be a three-point
specialist and and be effective in three
on three